it's coming up soon and we've all got
our hopes hey folks Doctor Who series 12
is right around the corner it is coming
up fast and before we get into it I
thought I would put on the record what
some of my hopes for series 12 are now I
am NOT an enormous fan of series 11 it
might actually be my least favorite
series I didn't hate everything about it
couple of the episodes I thought were
genuinely great and I've laid out in
pretty explicit detail what my problems
were and I felt the need to do that
because a lot of the Proms I have are
not the things that the most vocal
critics of series 11 tend to shout about
I had the same problem with last chat I
but I'm coming back hopeful because this
is still my favorite show and I want it
to be good so what I'm gonna talk about
here is just what I hope will happen or
not happen in series 12 none of this is
plot related none of this is who I want
them to do this story or that in like no
and I'm also not really taking to
account the things that are known
because we've seen clips of some of the
upcoming premiere spy fall we know some
of the creatures that are going to show
up we know certain things but I'm not
the kind of person like to dissect that
and try and paint a picture of what I
think is precisely going to happen so
like that's not really entering into
most of my thought processes on this
some of these are big ideas thematic
some of them are minor but let's get
through it so the first is I want them
to find a purpose for yes because I
don't think yes is a bad character but
the show is not done a lot with her
right now so far the most important
function she had was to hook us into
demons
the Punjab which was one of the best
episodes of series 11 but as a character
she didn't do a lot
she didn't contribute a lot some of the
perspective she brought to certain
events was also being brought by Rian or
by the doctor there hasn't been a lot to
distinguish her as an individual and I
hope that they'll find the time to do
that either by giving her a little bit
of her own arc because in series 11 you
know Graham and Ryan had an arc yes
didn't really so maybe they'll do that
or maybe they'll just find a function
she serves within the group that none of
the others fulfill
I would hope her background as a police
officer would in some way factor into
that and certainly give some groundwork
to do it but they haven't yet and I
really hope they do especially since
they're keeping a rabid crowd and TARDIS
if we kind of keep this many around have
a reason for them to be there so that's
the first one next up I really want them
to make the TARDIS feel like a home
again there's a couple of things that
contribute to this in series 11 the
TARDIS first of all we spent very little
time in there it was just it just got us
from place to place it never felt like
the home base that they returned to it
was just the vehicle and it didn't help
how darkly lit it was it didn't feel
like a place you would want to be a
place where you would want to just dwell
because the preet the other iterations
of the TARDIS that we've had in modern
era Doctor Who not all of them felt
super homey I would argue Matt Smith's
first TARDIS was the most felt like a
home especially with you know when he
had Amy and Rory and they kept coming
back there and spent a lot of time in
there but even going back to classic era
Doctor Who they would spend more time in
the console room that's where they would
come back to meet the doctor and the
companions and it never felt like
anybody wanted to get back inside the
TARDIS during series 11 other than like
that very first moment of them finding
it in the ghost Wineman that was a great
moment but after that it was basically
just their ride and nothing else and the
TARDIS should be more than that
and I kind of hope they'll they'll build
that up a little bit better next up okay
I need more focus on the doctor this is
another upshot of the fact that I don't
think it was a good idea to introduce a
four person TARDIS crew in a series
where we didn't know any of these
characters already especially a series
with fewer episodes I didn't feel like I
got this doctor I didn't feel like I
understood what Jodi Whitaker's approach
really was until the very end of series
11 and that frustrated me and I think
part of the reason that I felt that was
because she was sharing basically equal
time with the companions now that's not
inherently a bad thing but it did mean I
felt like out of those four the
characters who I understood best were
Ryan and Graham and while they're good
characters and I'm happy to know them
I'm here for the doctor I want to know
what this doctor so I want to get a
better sense of her I want her to be
more focused more front-and-center
deal more with how things affect her
directly because it felt like almost
everything got filtered through the
companions in some way in the previous
series and I'm not gonna say that didn't
work for some stories that worked very
well but I want more of the doctor
herself please give it to me all right
what else have I got
oh all right this is a minor nitpick you
want I really hope Jody but it could
change the way she's wielding the sonic
screwdriver because look plenty of
people made fun of Matt Smith treating
it like a magic wand cuz he was like
whoa honestly that didn't bother me all
that much and that never felt nearly as
much like a magic wand as does I hate
this big arm arch I hate this big
exaggerated motion it's a tool bring it
up and use it generally if you use it
it's cuz you need it don't do this
stop just don't that's a minor one but
it bugged me all right what else have I
got okay the last two are basically
interconnected so I'll lump them
together don't throw out everything
different you did in series 11 and don't
immediately bring back everything you
didn't use in series 11 this is about
the one area where I am going to take
into account some of the things we know
like the fact that older monsters and
aliens are coming back a number of them
and that makes me nervous because series
11 did quite a bit different it had
entirely self-contained stories it
really had no two parters it did little
cliffhanger connections from one to the
next but there weren't any two parters
there was no overarching story of the
entire thing the visual approach was
different there were no returning
monsters and also I felt like a lot more
thought went into the historical
episodes in particular and that's one
thing I definitely want them to retain
now this doesn't always work but in my
mind the best historical stories are
ones who take the historical figure and
show how what they were going through in
some way parallels stuff's still going
on
that's what Vincent and the doctor did
that's what demons of the Punjab did
that's what as much as I'm actually not
nearly as big a fan of it as most people
but that's what Rosa did and I admire it
for aiming for that even though I have
mixed feelings about the end results of
it and that's what I want the approach
to because in my mind the reason why I'm
pretty quick to usually say I don't
really like the historical episodes is
because I hate the approach that I feel
happens more often than not with modern
era Doctor Who which is oh look famous
historical person we squeeze Victorian
werewolves which has what to do with
anything it's vampires in Venice okay
right
I understand some people just like that
I get it but in my mind if you're going
to do a historical episode in a point of
Earth's history make what was going on
there
relevant to us and I feel like they
tried to do that with all of the
historically set episodes in series 11 I
don't think it worked in all of them I
don't think it really worked in the
witch hunters at all
I would debate how well it worked in
Rosa but definitely work better there I
thought it worked amazingly in demons of
the punjab but I admire that approach
and I want them to keep that but I
mentioned all the old creatures coming
back I'm not saying that I never wanted
them to bring back the various things
got that got dropped off and left behind
in series 11 things like two-parters old
villains series arts etc I just needed a
break from them and it's kind of ironic
that the series that gave me a break
from them was a series I ended up not
liking all that much but there you go
but I'm not saying those things can't
come back or that I never want them to
come back but if they all come back at
once in series 12 that smacks of a
creative team that doesn't have a plan
that basically is going well we tried
something different not enough people
connected to it bring everything back
that smacks of a lack of integrity a
lack of having a true sense of what you
intend to do with it to just go well we
did something didn't work let's do it
the way everyone expects us to yeah like
I I'm hoping that you know we're gonna
get we're gonna get two partners back at
the very least with the opening so okay
those are back and we're getting some of
old monsters I'm hoping that old
monsters are a minority of episodes and
I hope we don't go back to the mystery
box series Ark template I really hope
that because that basically would just
mean they brought back everything and
that that just feels like pandering and
again it feels like a lack of a plan Oh
of an intent and I want to give Chibnall
more benefit of the doubt than that but
I'm kind of afraid that that's what he's
gonna do
I want series 12 to retain some of the
elements that have brought to play the
approach it took to historical I'm not
gonna say never happened in previous
modern era Doctor Who episodes but it
happened very rarely and I saw that
proto applied to all three historical
even though it didn't work every time
the approach to cinematography love it
love the new look in the feel of the
thing please keep that and there are
things worth bringing back the sense of
the TARDIS as I mentioned you know there
are things to bring back but if it just
ends up being the trappings that that
would worry me we'll see what we get
premiers not too long from now I'm still
hopeful I want to love it I will always
want to love Doctor Who no matter who's
running it no matter what's going on I
want to love this show
we'll see if I do series 12 what do you
hope for whatever your thoughts are drop
something down to comments let's talk
about it there's stuff to do down there
as well because you can support me on
patreon helps me pay the bills I've also
got a tip jar on Pay Pal both links for
that down below comment subscribe like
share all that usual stuff but you also
don't have to do any of it cuz end of
the day folks here the council I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]